l'image du festival de cannes c'est une
pléiade de stars sur un tapis rouge du
glamour des paillettes mais ce soir
l'ouverture de l'édition 2008 a été
marqué par un ton différent plutôt grave
et politique
dominique poncet nathalie berthier la
direction du festival avait annoncé
cette 61ème édition serait recentré sur
le cinéma pur ce qui sous-entendait
moins de glamour et moins de paillettes
en accord avec les nouvelles ambitions
c'est le réalisateur claude lanzmann qui
avait été choisi pour ouvrir le nouveau
festival
il l'a fait après un interminable
discours sur sa vision du 7e art avec
beaucoup de gaieté aussi je déclare
ouvert le 61e festival accueille
mouvement juste avant le comédien
edouard baer avait insulté à cette
cérémonie sont ni remue son élégance et
sa légèreté
ozcan freestyle ou mezedjri pas à peu
près ça
et sean penn le président du jury avait
offert son humanisme et sa perspicacité
toujours sélectionné deux grands films
avec de grands acteurs réalisateurs
nouvel épisode du festival de beaune
plus austère que les précédentes cette
soirée d'ouverture s'est achevée par la
projection d'un film sur le chaos
engendré par une épidémie de cécité dans
un film passionnant mais sombre signé du
réalisateur brésilien fernando meireles
du tôt dans l'après-midi la pro 7 avait
quand même vécu des instants de grand
charme grâce notamment à la présence
éblouissante de madame di caprio
car quoi qu'on souhaitait qu'on annonce
cam n'échappera jamais totalement au
glamour tous les cinéphiles le savent le
cinéma même le plus sérieux engendre
toujours à un moment ou à un autre une
part de rêve